les groupes français bouygues et vinci
ont remporté le contrat de la
construction d'un nouveau sarcophage
autour du réacteur nucléaire de
tchernobyl qui avait explosé en avril 86
à chantilly estimé à 432 millions
d'euros qui devraient débuter dès le
mois prochain pour s'achever en 2012
patricia jean jacques botti
la route n'a rien d'effrayant
mais très vite le poste de contrôle nous
rappelle que nous entrons dans une zone
à risque
l'ennemi est invisible c'est la
radioactivité elle est partout sur le
sol dans l'air la poussière
tout a basculé dans la nuit du 26 avril
1986 le réacteur numéro 4 de la centrale
nucléaire de tchernobyl explose
à la hâte ses hommes surnommés les
liquidateurs vont au péril de leur vie
enveloppés le réacteur d'un sarcophage
de béton pour limiter les radiations
mais le mal s'est propagé aujourd'hui
encore ils continuent à faire des
victimes dans ce centre médical les
dossiers s'empilent et l'inquiétude 30
on a craint aujourd'hui ses yeux c'est
me n'est même pas une crainte
puisqu'elles sont là c'est comment on va
pouvoir faire face aux leucémies qui
apparaissent et qui continue car 21 ans
plus tard le sarcophage se fissure ils
fuient pour éviter une nouvelle
catastrophe
un dôme hermétique de 18 mille tonnes va
être construit au dessus du réacteur
accidenté
une manière de tourner la page de
dédiaboliser le nucléaire on ne
relancera pas je pense le nucléaire dans
le monde sans avoir fait accepter cette
énergie par la population il y à un
préalable
c'est réglé la solution régler le cas de
tchernobyl or ce contrat est un pas
gigantesque dans cette solution la
construction de ce nouveau sarcophage a
fait l'objet de tractations pendant plus
de 15 ans
en ukraine les autorités s'exprime peu
sur le sujet je ne suis pas à l'aise ici
pour commenter le travail des
gouvernements précédents au revoir
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
le nouveau gouvernement ukrainien a
réussi en quelques semaines a assuré une
avancée considérable à ce dossier cinq
années de travaux seront nécessaires
pour construire un nouveau sarcophage
une nouvelle enceinte de confinement qui
devrait mettre hors d'état de nuire le
réacteur accidenté pendant coup de son
temps de quoi rassurer la communauté
internationale
mais surtout les hommes les femmes et
les enfants qui vivent dans la région